I think the corrupting influence is one
of my favorite commander pre-cons in
recent years most of the commander
pre-cons try to do too many things right
out of the box but the corrupting
influence deck is pretty focused get
poison counters on your opponents and
win the game
so let's take a look at the pre-con and
see how we can upgrade it for just 25
bucks
let's quickly go over the two commanders
in the deck first up we have ixahal
Scion of a track sir for one generic a
white a black and a green you get a 2-5
forexian angel with flying vigilance and
toxic too and corrupted at the beginning
of your end step each opponent who has
three or more poison counters Exiles the
top card Affair Library face down you
may look at and play those cards for as
long as they remained exiled and you may
spend Mana as there were Mana of any
color to cast those spells
now before we go any further let's
quickly break down the difference
between toxic and infect as the deck has
creatures with both of those abilities
a creature within fact deals damage to a
player in the form of poison counters so
a two power insect creature would give a
player two poison counters and would not
change their life total
a creature would in fact also deals
damage to creatures in the form of minus
one minus one counters permanently
reducing the opponent's creature's power
and toughness
an important thing to note this applies
to any damage the creature deals not
just combat damage so if you gave Goblin
sharpshooter in fact it could use the
ability to put either a poison counter
on a player or a minus one minus one
counter on a creature
a creature with toxic on the other hand
deals regular combat damage to creatures
and when they deal combat damage to a
player they deal regular combat damage
reducing their life total and give them
a number of poison counters equal to the
number next to their toxic ability
so ixa hell is a great card Advantage
engine the more players we get to three
poison counters the more cards we get to
make use of
their ability also says you may play
those cards instead of you make carso's
cards which means you can also play the
lands you get off the ability to
now if you want to go down a more
aggressive route you can swap out ixa
Hill for visuals the Doom Hive for two
generic a white a black and a green you
get a 3-3 with Menace and toxic two and
when visgras enters the battlefield
create three one one colorless forexian
might artifact creature tokens with
toxic one and this creature can't block
fish grass also gets plus one plus one
for each poison counter your opponents
have
so as you can clearly see vishgrass and
friends want to get into the Red Zone
and Dole out as many poison counters as
you can
I don't think the way I've structured
the deck is optimal for fish grass as I
think with them you'll want to focus on
creating buffing and protecting your
tokens so if you want to see a deck
specifically built around vishgrass let
me know in the comments down below
okay on to the ixa hill upgrades
so to start let's quickly look at the
four lands I've added to the deck access
tunnel Rogues passage mirax and tyrite
Sanctum
access tunnel and Rogues passage
effectively do the same thing for three
Mana access tunnel lets a creature with
power 3 or less become unblockable and
this pairs perfectly with ixa health as
they only have two power
rogue's passage does the same thing but
for four mana and it can Target any
creature and the fact that both lands
means you're more likely to keep these
unblockable abilities around for the
whole game
limericks Taps for any color the Turner
enters the battlefield and then it can
only tap for colorless after that and
for three Mana it can create a 1-1
colorless artifact mic creature with
toxic one and this creature can't block
the ability to create a threat every
turn for just three Mana is really good
especially because it's a toxic creature
and with all the abilities we have in
this deck to make our creatures
unblockable you will likely be able to
kill someone with just a swarm of mites
the last land in this section is tyrite
sanctum and I think this card should be
in every single commander deck it Taps
for a colorless and has for two Mana we
can give any legendary creature a plus
one plus one counter and turn them into
a god
repeatable plus one plus one effects are
great especially when you're running a
proliferate deck
and finally it has pay for sacrifice
tirade sanctum and put an indestructible
counter on target God
so ideally we want to make exahil a God
and then make them indestructible
that's not only going to make ixa Hill
difficult to remove but they also become
an excellent blocker thanks to their
inbuilt vigilance ability
okay with Lance out of the way it's on
to the creatures oh what's this creature
oh it's just the Subscribe button be
sure to tap that for more upcoming
Commander content and tap that like
button if you want to increase your luck
on your next pack opening
okay first up we have eternal witness a
three Mana two one that has the ETB
return Target card from your graveyard
to your hand
as a pseudo infect deck your creatures
are likely to be the target of removal
so Eternal witness gives you the chance
to give them a second shot at life it's
also an excellent way at fetching any of
our previously used removal or even
tutors out of the bin so we can use them
again
Eternal witness is one of those cards
that belongs in nearly every Green deck
next up there's bloated contaminator a
new addition from forexia all will be
one for three Mana we get a 4 4 with
trample toxic one and whenever bloated
contaminator deals combat damage to a
player proliferate
a really nice blocker and attacker in
the early game and that proliferate
ability is always relevant especially
when we pair it with the next couple of
creatures
so the goal with this next set of
creatures is to make sure your creatures
are either unblockable or in such a way
that your opponents don't want to block
them
so first we have another Commander
favorite of mine sarath the Viper's Fang
for for Mana we get a 3-4 that gives all
your tapped unlikely attacking creatures
death touch and untapped creatures you
control hex proof and for one mana and
tapping sarath you can untap another
Target creature or Lance you control
so giving all of our 1-1 toxic or infect
creatures death touch makes them that
much more harder to block and if your
opponents aren't blocking your creatures
it doesn't matter how much life they're
on 10 poison counters and they lose the
game
if death touch isn't convincing enough
how about champion of lamphole champion
of lamhole is a three Mana 1-1 that says
creatures with power less than champion
of lamphole can't block creatures you
control and whenever another creature
you control enters the battlefield put a
plus one plus one counter on champion of
lamhole
Champion can get out of hand real
quickly and works really well with our
token generators such as visgras for
action swarmlord and the Merricks if any
of your opponents are playing tokens
they're gonna have a hard time blocking
your creatures with champion on the
battlefield
our last new creature add-on to the deck
is Park height Mavericks Park height
Maverick is a three Mana 2-2 with
Dethrone which means whenever this
creature attacks the player with the
highest slide total it gets a plus one
plus one counter
in addition it can't be blocked by
creatures with power two or less so no
chant blocking there and lastly whenever
Park height Maverick deals combat damage
to player or dies proliferate
so not only does this creature continue
to buff themselves they can also give
opponents additional poison counters it
can put more plus one plus one
characters on champion of lambholt
making our creatures even harder to
block another excellent pickup
moving out of the creature space we've
got two more enchantments to add to the
list first up we have stronghold Arena a
two minor black enchantment that we can
kick for a single white and or green it
says when stronghold Arena enters the
battlefield you gained three life for
each time it was kicked and whenever one
or more creatures you control deal
combat damage to a player you may reveal
the top card of your library and put it
into your hand if you do you lose life
equal to its minor value with the
average Mana value of Our Deck just
being two stronghold arena is a nice
cheap way to draw some extra cards
especially if our creatures aren't being
blocked our final enchantment is
probably the best card out of all the
upgrades and one I would look to pick up
first
here's behind the scenes a three Mana
black enchantment From Shadows over
innistrad
this three minor enchantment gives all
our creatures skulk which means our
creatures can't be blocked by creatures
with greater power
and it has an activated ability for five
Mana to give all our creatures plus one
plus one until the end of turn
combine this with champion of lamphole
and all of our creatures are now
effectively unblockable
moving on to artifacts I simply swapped
out commandosphere for ever flowing
chalice this zero minor artifact has
multi-kicker 2 and enters the
battlefield with charge counters on it
equal to the number of times it was
kicked it then Taps for colorless Mana
equal to that number
so effectively ever flowing chalice
produces half the amount of Mana you've
put into it however because we run
proliferate cards we can easily increase
the number of charge counters on this
artifact and quickly increase the amount
of Mana it produces
already on to the last section instance
and sorceries for instance I've added
two more flexible pieces of removal with
Mythos of netheroy and a generous gift
generous gift is an excellent three Mana
removal spell that can Target any
permanent and turn it into a vanilla 3-3
and Mythos of netheroy is a three Mana
creature removal for Just Two colorless
and a black or if you spend a green a
white and a black you can destroy any
non-land permanent instead
Lauren's Escape is another excellent
Commander card I would look to add to
almost any deck playing white for a
single white Miner we can give an
artifact or creature or most likely our
commander hex proof and indestructible
and as an added bonus you can also scry
one
for sorceries I've added rampant growth
to help with our ramp and I swapped out
the board wipes for white Sun's Twilight
white Sun's Twilight is the infect
version of Marshall coup for seven Mana
you get to destroy all creatures but
leave behind a small army of toxic mites
which might just be able to knock out
someone out of the game as players try
to recover their board
The Other Board wipe is dusk to dawn an
excellent utility card for just four
Mana you can destroy all creatures with
power 3 or greater which is perfect
because IXL slips right under that with
just two power
and on the aftermath side you can cast
Dawn for five Mana which returns all
creatures from our graveyard with power
2 or less to our hand
most of our infect and toxic creatures
have two or less power so being able to
refill our hand is excellent
diabolic Tudor is just a single piece of
much needed card selection it can help
us grab either a board wipe a piece of
removal or a way to make our creatures
unblockable and win the game or it could
potentially grab our sneaky win
condition which we're going to talk
about now the final card I added to this
deck is plain wide celebration this
seven Mana sorcery can potentially win
us the game out of nowhere
let's quickly go over the card
for two green and five generic we get to
choose four modes and we can choose the
same mode more than once
so we can either create a multi-colored
2-2 citizen creature return Target
permanent card from our graveyard to our
hand
we can proliferate or we can gain for
life
so let's look at it this way everyone
knows once you're on 10 poison counters
you lose the game
but what if you've managed to get
everyone to six counters well now you
can just simply cast plain white
celebration proliferate four times and
kill the whole table
so there we have it there's the 25
budget upgrade if you're looking to
splash some more money into this deck
I've added some suggestions in the
considering section of the decklist on
moxfield link in the description if
there are any other new forexia
Commander decks you would like to see
let me know in the comments down below
be sure to check out this Deck Tech if
you haven't already
thanks for watching and I'll see you
guys in the next one